[موسيقى]
ملاذ أجنبي في ضواحي أبو ظبي
هو منظر رائع لكنه يقع في واحدة
من أكثر المسطحات المائية ملوحة في
العالم ولهذا السبب التقيت بالعالم
كارمل تشيليش هنا مرحباً كمال مرحباً
كريستينا مرحباً ، كيف حالك شكراً
من الجيد أن أراك سعيدًا لرؤيتك أيضًا ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك لأنه
أخذني إلى الخليج العربي ، إنه
يبحث عن طرق جديدة ومبتكرة
لجعل الأسمنت مكونًا رئيسيًا في
صناعة البناء وملوثًا بيئيًا رئيسيًا رائعًا
لذلك يبدو رائعًا جدًا.  نظيف في الواقع ولكن
هذا في الواقع مالح جدًا ، لذا من حيث
التركيز يمكنني القول أنه 40
جرامًا لكل لتر ، لذا فهو مالح حقًا
بعد تحلية المياه ، حيث
يزيد التركيز حوالي مرتين
أو حوالي ثلاثة أضعاف
تحلية المياه التي تتضمن تحويل
الماء المالح من  من المحيط إلى
مياه صالحة للشرب ، تمر مياه البحر
من خلال مصانع معالجة كبيرة ويتم
ضخ الملح المتبقي المسمى بالمحلول الملحي
مرة أخرى في المحيط ،
لذا فهذه مشكلة حقيقية إنها
مشكلة حقيقية ولكن لدينا حل لذلك
نستفيد من هذه المياه المالحة ونصنع
معمل أجنبي للبيئة أجرى كمال
تجارب علمية على هذا المحلول الملحي الذي نحتاجه
لإزالة الكربون من صناعة الأسمنت
لأنه مسؤول عن ثمانية
بالمائة من انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون التي يصنعها الإنسان ،
وجد أنه يحتوي على تركيزات عالية
من المغنيسيوم وهو مركب لا
ينتج ثاني أكسيد الكربون
فماذا  نحن نقوم باستخدام هذه
العلامة التجارية المرفوضة من خطة تحلية المياه
وتطبيق كيمياء بسيطة للغاية ، فنحن
نضيف خليطًا كيميائيًا فعالًا من حيث التكلفة
ثم نقوم بعملية التوجيه
والطرد المركزي مما يعني أننا
نفصل السائل الصلب ونستخدم
هذا الجزء الصلب لصنع الأسمنت هذا  هذا هو
المنتج النهائي هذا هذا هذا
بعد يوم واحد الآن كمال
يتطلع إلى مستقبل ما وراء معمله [
موسيقى]
لم يطبق هذه المادة في
الصناعة ، لذا نحن الآن في
إثبات مراحل المفهوم وبمجرد أن نكون
قادرين  لإثارة المفهوم وإنتاج
كمية كبيرة من المواد سنكون قادرين
على تطبيقها في الصناعة
عندما يفعل كمال يقول
بيئته في طرق أقل ملوحة
يتم إلقاؤها في محيطاتنا
وأسمنت جديد ببصمة كربونية أقل
كريستينا ماكفارلين CNN
[موسيقى]